anything you want good you can have
so claiming work hard to get it when you
get it reach back hold someone else up
each one teach one
don't just aspire to make a living
aspire to make a difference you'll never
see a u-haul behind a hearse
I'll say it again you'll never see you
all behind a first now I've been blessed
to make hundreds of millions of dollars
in my life I can't take it and neither
can you
so it's not how much you have it's what
you do with watching path and we all
have different gifts some money some
love some patience some no need to touch
people but we all have it use it share
it that's what counts
not what you drive is not what you're
flying in not what kind of house you
bought you mama you just watched two
amazing clips from Denzel Washington
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]